let's talk about functional
neurodiversity what i mean by that is we
have a pandemic happening in modernity
where young kids that are functionally
neurodiverse are trying to be funneled
into archaic economic machinery
positions and they don't fit their
unique artistic expression cannot live
in those old archaic roles yes there are
serious neural miss communicative
diseases where people struggle with just
being now there are many ways of
providing solutions to those in their
own miss communicative diseases that
scientists are at the edge of what's
known trying to help but there is
something seriously wrong with the way
that we are trying to push functionally
neurodiverse kids into positions in the
economic machinery where they just do
not think I can give you so many
examples of kids that are young
around teenage or even preteen years
that are doing extremely eccentric
behaviors and these hyper unusual kids
are doing things like watching dozens or
even hundreds of countless hours on a
very specific theme that they're
interested in on the internet on
internet videos and they're finding out
that they're fascinated with that
specific subject that they will go to
the ends of what is known in that
subject at such a young age and they're
becoming masters given their
neuroplasticity in their obsession with
that concept that in the span of just a
week or even sometimes just a couple
days they'll run up to their mom and dad
interrupt them in whatever activity the
parents are doing and they'll just
lecture like a university professor on a
very complex theory that they learn from
the internet
this is very common that we have what
we're classifying as functionally
neurodiverse kids into the archaic codes
of that confessionary
it's up to us as a civilization to
identify functional neurodiversity and
those unique artistic expressions that
are definitely being catalyzed by the
computational generation and the
internet generation and create new codes
create new infrastructures for those
unique neurodiverse minds to fully
express their genius in the world
this has been a public service
announcement about functional neural
diversity and I also highly encourage
you to look into Eric Weinstein thoughts
and work on this subject as well he is a
huge role model for me in this field
and just also trying to push forward
people into understanding this specific
dilemma that were all going through
build the new codes that enable these
brilliant minds to fully express
themselves in the world build the new
jobs load the new infrastructures build
the new ways that these artists to fully
express their genius in the world
because we don't even know how many kids
were Dukey with drugs and really they
could be expressing themselves their
genius on updating society's code for
highest attention
you